Every getaway should be fun and relaxing.
Prepare to ensure your trip to the water park is a splashing event.
You will need: A computer with Internet access,...
...food and beverages, a bathing suit, sunscreen,...
...goggles, small plastic bags, a camera, and maps.
Optional: A room with a refrigerator and microwave.
Step 1: Call the water park and see if they are offering any promotions.
Check their website for deals.
Reserve a room with a refrigerator and microwave.
Step 2: Pack food and beverages.
Vending machines and restaurants at water parks can be very expensive.
Step 3: Pack the necessities, such as a bathing suit, sunscreen, goggles,...
...and small plastic bags to keep your cell phone and money dry.
Step 4: Bring your camera to capture all the great memories you will make.
Step 5: Get thorough directions to and from the water park.
Keep maps in your car's glove compartment and keep the park's phone number handy.
Step 6: Arrive early and stay late.
Most hotels will let you enjoy the water park hours before check-in...
...and let you stay in the park after you check out.
Did you know? There were over 180 indoor water parks in 2007.